les navires et bonsoir disparu le 28
janvier dernier jacques villeret été
l'un des acteurs les plus touchants du
cinéma français on l'a vu en 1981 jouer
l'extraterrestre dans la soupe aux choux
en 86 l'été en pente douce 188 le dîner
de cons
ce qui lui a valu un césar sans oublier
la scène avec la contrebasse vous avez
partagé son quotidien pendant 25 ans et
aujourd'hui vous témoigner dans un livre
publié chez flammarion qui s'appelle un
jour tout ira bien
voilà alors votre père était producteur
de cinéma vous êtes né dans le milieu
voulu être actrice au départ fréquenté
un endroit qui s'appelait le sherwood où
il y avait eu steve balmer dussollier et
la première fois vous voyez jacques
villeret il est là il est il a un peu
saoul déjà oui c'est vrai qu'il avait
une tendance à aso blier un petit peu
dans l'air par l'alcool ensuite vous
resté cinq ans sans le voir et vous le
voyez en 1978 fait connaissance il vous
invite à son one man show et après le
spectacle qui vous invite à dîner et ils
vous révèlent sa sa blessure en fait
c'est à dire son père algérien
oui c'est vrai et il a vécu pendant des
années sous une autre identité et je
crois que ça a été une très grande
blessure évidemment qu'il a suivi toute
sa vie puisque il a découvert une façon
difficile par le directeur de
l'établissement scolaire qui lui a rendu
ses papiers le livret de famille que il
ne portait pas du tout ce nom là ce soir
là au fil des eaux file des verts le
personnage sa sombre et il finit par
vous dire qu'il n'est pas programmé pour
vivre vous en déduisez quoi ça m'émeut
évidemment je rentrerai en train dé
immédiatement compassion alors le
lendemain ils vous envoient des roses
rouges
vous êtes séduit tu parles par l'acteur
évidemment mais vous n'êtes pas
tellement séduite par un par l'homme
mais c'est pas ça c'est que en fait moi
je suis maman
j'ai décidé de vivre seule avec mon
enfant donc je ne suis pas prête à
rentrer en amour avec qui que ce soit
c'est difficile quand on a un enfant de
le remarquer dans une histoire
on a le sentiment les envois de bouquins
qui s'accroche à vous complètement à ce
moment-là il y comprend peut-être que
que je suis prête à l'aider à le
soutenir je ne sais pas ça laissait ses
mystérieux là vous rentrez donc dans une
relation amoureuse et dévastatrice très
intense il boit beaucoup et vous dites
quand il boit il devient agressif
hélas cette colère qui remonte à
l'enfance ase tout à fait c'est une
chose qui ne digère pas je vais je me
suis battu toute ma vie
toute ma vie je me suis battu toute ma
vie j'ai espéré ce livre s'appelle un
jour tout ira bien
parce que jacques m'a écrit ce mot qui
figurent dans ce livre mon seul amour un
jour tout ira bien je te le promets je
t'aime jacques et je me suis accroché à
ses toutes petites phrases un jour tout
ira bien
quand quand il a bu il vous fait peur
ben oui ça fait peur parce que quelqu'un
qui boit quelqu'un qu'ils sont en prise
d'une drogue
il n'est plus tout à fait lui même et il
y avait ces espèces de crise qui pouvait
ressembler à l'hélium très minces oui où
tout d'un coup oui il y avait des dd
il était il était violent mais c'est
vrai qu'il casse et tout ça fait peur
ça fait peur il avait une double
personnalité j'arrête et l'alcool lui
réussit c'est pas bien ça le faisait pas
bien voyager comme tous les alcoolo
comme tous les drogués il vous dit je
peux m'arrêter quand je veux et on est
dans le déni je crois quand on est dans
cette maladie d' alors ils traînent
toutes les nuits dehors en fait il
disparaît 3 jours 3 nuits
sûrement le seuil de sa résistance vous
le laisser partir vous âgées laisse pas
partir
difficile de récupérer quelqu'un moi au
départ je suivais mais comme je vous dis
moi j'avais j'avais mon métier et
j'avais mon enfant je ne pouvais pas
comme ça va le suivre de sur le chaman
en faire ce pas c'était pas évident vous
saviez où il avait quand il partait
comme ça a toujours pas toujours j'ai
découvert plus tard des choses un peu
mais bon je crois que je me cachais je
me vois aller un peu la face et vous le
voyez arriver le lendemain en général
c'est les flics qui l'ont mis dans un
taxi mais oui oui souvent alors au bout
d'un moment ce qui est terrible c'est
que il boit autant quand il est heureux
que quand il est malheureux cirque en
fait quand claude berri lui propose de
jouer ugolin en jean de florette et
manon des sources
il très heureux il boit et quand il
apprend que simone signoret yves montand
ne veulent pas de lui
il boit parce qu'il est malheureux donc
il boit tout le temps c'est récurrent
piscine venu ça s'est installée petit à
petit pour arriver à l'issue que
malheureuses du 28 janvier 2005 alors
vous dites que l'alcool l'amène à
manquer de discernement dans sa carrière
sur quinze jours on lui propose trois
hommes et un couffin et il veut pas le
faire
oui on y passait à côté il a regretté
bien sûr mais bon c'est pas si grave
alors problème c'est que l'alcool
l'obligé annulé un certain nombre de
représentations et peggy t il faut
rembourser dans ce cas là non remboursés
vie c'est très dommage pour le public
qui s'est déplacé qui a réservé
longtemps à l'avancé
c'est arrivé
et toujours ça revient comme un
leitmotiv dans votre bouquin je m'arrête
quand je veux un jour tout ira bien
c'est sans arrêt au bout d'un moment
vous y croyez plus vous si g j ai
toujours cru parce que quand ahmadi est
arrivé vraiment qu'il ya eu un non
posées sur cette surce sur ceux sur sur
les résultats de la bo je me suis dit va
réagir il va réagir comme tout le monde
il va avoir peur de la mort et puis
apparemment non il finit par rencontrer
son père biologique se aurait pu
effectivement provoquer une
transformation chez lui mais en fait ils
devaient avoir il y avait fait fantasmer
sur ce père mais il y avait aussi il
avait toute latitude pour partir à sa
recherche
donc il s'agit là jamais fait la
démarche
ils avaient peur de cette démarche si
c'est arrivé pendant au début de la
contrebasse à hébertot 1 et je crois que
ça a tout fait basculer parce que la
rencontre n'a pas été celle qu'il
espérait ça n'a rien arrangé disant
voilà
non je crois que c'est pire je crois que
ça fait basculer je crois se trouvant
devant cette réalité qui était assez
triste et s'est senti une seconde fois
abandonnée puisque là
cette rencontre n'a pas été celle qu'il
espérait il n'y a pas eu d'amour ya pas
eu de retrouvailles d'amour vous avez
songé à le quitter
à un moment on voulait divorcer non oui
je menaçais c'était moi ou l'alcool
mais je l'aurais jamais fait parce que
je suis incapable de c'est une maladie
on laisse pas tomber un cancéreux on
laisse pas tomber un alcoolique non plus
ils voulaient pas voir la réalité parce
que quand on lui disait tu vas voir une
cirrhose du foie il disait c'est pas
grave le fois ça repousse c'est un vrai
régal colossal et un soir il fait une
tentative de suicide avec des somnifères
un matin en rentrant ivre mort et vous
roue de coups quand même
oui pendant mon sommeil c'est une crise
de delirium tremens puisque il l'avait
il était absent et puis c'est plus
souvenu ne se souvenait pas où c'était
c'était impossible
c'était pas lui alors je vous finissez
par le par le vivrai je n'en pouvais
plus je me sentais mourir - m et je lui
dis c'est l'axé l'elysee il aura plus
d'alcool à la maison parce que c'est je
peux pas voir cette déchéance ne peut
pas être témoin je peux pas cautionner
pas cautionner cette mort donc je lui je
lui dira plus d'alcool à la maison je
sais pas pourquoi j'ai ajouté souffre du
vinaigre et de l'alcool à 90 parce qu'on
en a besoin dans une maison eh ben le
choix évidemment au stade de la maladie
je ne n'étais que perdante
donc il est il a respecté ma demande et
donc il est parti s'est installé à
l'hôtel aura de la maison alors là quand
vous vous séparez il passe du sauve moi
je vais te pourrir la vie quoi il a une
attitude si quelqu'un me quittes je je
ne vais pas su plier
je n'allais pas le supplier de rester
les nations donc il l'a senti un
désamour
donc ça l'a blessé à une blessure
narcissique
aussi ils demandent le divorce et vous
dites dans votre bouquin qui vous coupe
les vivres
il ya un truc est pas très clair quand
même parce que c'est vous qui gériez ses
finances donc comment il peut juger est
passé finit non ils vous coupe les
vivres vraiment oui et non sa soeur
ghislaine dit que c'est vous qui avez
vidé ses comptes
bah écoute et qu'on demande apporte les
preuves
j'aurais été très content de vider les
comptes auraient dû le faire
non j'ai pas vidé les comptes de
monsieur ville reine c'est
extraordinaire a dit qu'il n'était pas
violent finalement ghislaine je ne sais
pas elle dit que c'est lui la victime
écoutez j'ai ce type alors tous ces gens
ont un double discours puisque quand il
est décédé
c'est beaucoup par les gens bons
rapports principe avec ma belle famille
et elle m'a dit cette phrase importante
mais tu sais bien que jacques il n'avait
jamais tort donc ils ont souffert aussi
de sa mauvaise foi
enfin de son déni qui dénie d'alcool qui
dit kiki passait dans la vie courante
auprès des amis vous avez très mauvaise
presse
comment je pense pas votre mauvaise
presse et ça n'a pas d'importance je
crois que j'ai été importante pour
beaucoup de gens de la profession
pendant des années puisque j'ai si
jackie est arrivé là où ils étaient
c'est parce que j'étais là parce que je
le soutenais parce que je l'aidais aussi
son talent aussi quand même mais oui non
mais évidemment mais je ne pense pas que
jacques aurait vécu jusque là je dis il
ya d'autres amis communs qui sont qui
sont toujours auprès de moi et qui sont
excessivement choquée qu'ils ont été
excessivement choquée et outrée et
révolté par son attitude mais bon encore
une fois ça ne regarde que nous je peux
vous poser une question un peu bête vous
dites que ça regarde que vous pourquoi
vous écrivez ce livre alors c'est autre
chose parce que moi j'ai mené un combat
contre l'alcool donc quand il est mort
jacques je suis j'ai été prise par la
colère et la révolte qu'on puisse donner
la mort comme ça j'ai souffert en
silence pendant très longtemps
pendant des années et c'était au moment
de sa mort qu'il fallait que j'en parle
parce que j'ai pensé aussi à tous ces
gens qui vit qui le vivent dans l'ombre
à tout l'entourage qui en souffrent et
essayer de faire passer un message dire
à ces gens qui boivent et qu'ils se
détruisent que l'issue est fatale
gérard vous l'avez connu vous jacques
villeret oui messieurs vue ouais on a
effet papy fait de la résistance en
cévennes mais oui c'était un garçon qui
pouvait être
double oui très très très drôle très
sympa titre est avec une blessure
évidemment au fond quoi et puis des jeux
les vues dans son dernier spectacle
n'était pas au mieux de sa forme quoi ça
faisait un peu peine
non je me c'est lourd quoi tout ça
difficile
je sais pas j'ai pas lu je lis donc je
pose pas la vie est ce que c'est est-ce
que c'est utile oui c'est peut-être
utile pour vous ce que c'est utile de
parler de la face cachée en 5 ans
quelque part moi je m'en fous je voyais
un acteur magnifique qui me faisait rire
qui m'émeut veh qui soit alcoolique pâle
coliques et homosexuels hétérosexuels
non gérard on s'en fout que le verset il
ya beaucoup d'acteurs qui méritent pas
faki il vaut mieux pas les connaître
moi j'ai connu plein d'acteurs
formidables qu'il fallait mieux pas
connaître le contraire aussi je pense
que c'est pas très important ce qui par
essence que non mais c'est pas ça c'est
que je le fais verlaine était le plus
grand des poètes connus d'un oui j'étais
jeune mais c'était sans doute une manne
une l'humanité assez incertaine donc je
crois que c est ce que ça très sympa
dans la vie voilà j'aimerai vous vous
posez des questions sur l'utilité de
faire ce genre de livre manon enfin je
sais pas j'ai pas produire une réaction
ça aurait été un inconnu j'aurais écrit
ce livre il n'aurait pas été publiés oui
peut-être que si l'argent que vous avez
gagné vous allez en faire quoi
qu'est-ce qu'on croyait gérant faire
j'élève ma famille j'aide ma famille si
c'est pour dénoncer l'alcool peut-être
donner une partie bien sûr mais bien sûr
mais je
je je je vais aider à là dedans merci un
jour que tu vas bien
c'est un mario
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de linars
dit tu es abonné vous mettez un pouce
bleus